hi welcome back to the show let's walk
through the solution for this one
because it's just a little bit tricky
first we need to keep some sort of count
on how many of the acids have been
loaded and how many were waiting to load
to do this we created a nifty little
object here that has a count that
represents how many objects have been
loaded a total which is how many objects
were waiting to load and then they give
in callback function now we want to take
our code which previously only loaded
one asset an issue to call back and add
a loop around it so that we can do this
for the entire asset list now there's
one tricky thing here is that once we
actually load an object and get a
callback for it we want to do some logic
before we issue the callback so for
instance once the first image is loaded
we don't want to issue the callback then
we want to wait until the entire set has
been loaded for this we added a new
function called on loaded callback this
function given an asset that's been
loaded will actually go through and
increase the count on the batch once our
count equals the total number of assets
we're waiting for we actually issue the
callback at that time with this setup
you have the ability to issue a batch of
assets load them and when they've all
been loaded you finally get your
callback